Embattled Los Angeles
City Councilman
Kevin De Leon is still facing
repeated calls to resign
over a scandal
sparked by racist comments caugh
Other members of the council
have resigned
or planned
to because of this whole scandal
but De Leon is defiant,
refusing to do so.
He's encountered fierce backlash
since an audio
recording of this racist convers
with other council members
leaked back in October.
And he's since largely
been out of the public eye.
Returning to the council really
for the first time just on Frida
And look what happened when De L
his return to the council chambe
Yeah.
So I'm just I'm going to have to
I'm going to have to call
a brief recess of this meeting
Joining me right now
for an exclusive interview, L.A.
City Councilman Kevin de Leon.
Councilman, thank you for coming
I know that
we've been working on trying
to have this conversation
for quite some time.
Friday's meeting
was the first that you've attend
I believe, since
October 11th or early October.
Were you surprised
by the reaction of the council m
who left in protest
and also people in the community
who are clearly still very upset
and not over this scandal?
Well, good morning, Kate.
Unfortunately, I wasn't quite su
by a handful of individuals
who serve on the city council
within walking out.
Obviously, it's unfortunate,
but nonetheless,
I came on Friday to get back to
The past two months,
I've been taking a lot of reflec
working with my constituents,
as well as having conversations
not just with my constituents
in the district,
but with constituents are folks
outside of district with many co
but in particular
the African-American community.
Let me underscore something.
This is something that
I have profoundly
taken a lot of reflection.
But I rolled up my sleeves
and I'm getting back to work,
engaging with my constituents
every single day.
And that's why we turned back on
There is in the city charter,
it does say that an office becom
when an office holder
is absent from the city
without the consent of the counc
for more than 60 days.
Your attendance
on Friday
to that council meeting
was either,
depending on how you count it,
either exactly the 60 day mark
or just before
I know
you said you wanted to return to
to get back to work,
but is that also why you showed
in order to avoid a fight?
Because.
No, because today, for example,
we have a council meeting
and I'll be attending the counci
today as well.
Let me be very clear.
90 to 95% of the work
for the city council in Los
Angeles is actually done
with city departments and city h
And that's
what I've been exactly doing wit
and my staff have been wonderful
during this very difficult time.
We've received
a tremendous amount of support
from the community,
and that's why we continue to se
I continue to serve
because, you know,
the stories that you just talked
with regards to inflation
and how it's impacted,
especially disproportionate
commute of color.
The district
I represent
by far
and large is a Latino
immigrant community.
I am the epicenter for homelessn
not just in the city of L.A.,
but nationwide.
That's why I continue to serve,
because folks have been struggli
especially during
the post-pandemic,
as well
as a threat of being evicted
because of the eviction moratori
that will soon be lifted
in the city of Los Angeles.
So just so everyone
understands and I know you know
this, every leader
involved in this scandal
either, including the now former
council president,
they're all they've all resigned
or are leaving
because of the mess
that this has created.
Why are you not resigning
I know you say you still have wo
but other members, the points
that the council members
are making still today
about this whole thing is
that they say that the city cann
if you are still there.
And one member
saying that your continued prese
on the council
is causing severe and ongoing ha
Well, let me say this, Kate.
And let me be very clear about t
In a democracy,
the voters make the decision, no
who are in the peanut gallery
or political pundits
or even in my own colleagues.
You know,
tens of millions of Americans go
every single day
with folks that they don't like.
But you know what they do every
they get up and they go to work
and they don't have the luxury
perhaps of some folks to
when they want to walk out.
I'm here to do the business
of my constituents.
And that's
what I've worked for tirelessly
That's what I'm going to continu
I can tell you this,
and I want to underscore
emphasize the fallout.
If you don't think I'm profoundl
sorry, you know,
for participating that meeting
or for not standing up
and shutting
that meeting down and shutting d
the vitriolic comments from the
of the council who did eventuall
That's something
I'm forever will be sorry for.
And that's why I'm having
two constructive conversations,
with folks outside the community
I totally understand.
But it wasn't
it wasn't just that you didn't s
You also took part in the conver
I mean, in it
you said you compared
the young black child
of a fellow councilman
to being an accessory
like a luxury handbag.
Well, let me give this some cont
because one thing I really wish
that the media
did was provide context and sort
it was much more nuanced
than just general comments.
I mean, I can
I can play it for them
and we don't need to.
Let's play then.
Let everybody hear what you said
Here, let me play this.
What I want to say.
Well,
let's play the one you're laughi
Yeah.
Triathlete during Black History
I give up council,
you know, one
that I remember a little bit
better.
We when we go do the parade,
just like we just.
I went away and have a snack, yo
Yeah.
I went in the yard bag or the fr
the Louis Vuitton bag.
I mean, you have said in
subsequent interviews
and you say you're profoundly so
that you have failed in leadersh
and accept responsibility.
But what exactly was is the miss
What exactly was the mistake
that you made
that you were apologizing for?
Well, obviously,
that was a
it was I shouldn't have said wha
because it was actually a commen
I was criticizing actually Counc
Nuria Martinez for her penchant
for luxury handbags.
You know, and it's,
again, you know, apologetic.
I shouldn't have said
that, you know, clearly
and have apologized to Mike Vonn
and as well as his family.
That's something that,
you know,
I should have said, you
know, and apologize for that.
It was my inartful way of critic
then council president, a woman
known Martinez
for a penchant for luxury handba
before.
Before I let you
go, I did want to ask you,
because you're on tape
you're on tape
making fun of a colleague's
young black child
when there's a racist conversati
that's occurring that colleagues
a fellow Democrat
now still considers
you and his words are a vile
racist is how he puts it.
Councilman,
you've been absent from the comm
since October.
The council meetings have been s
multiple times over this scandal
to committee members,
community members protesting
and the committee
not being able to operate the co
And then the last week,
you got into a physical fight
no matter who started it.
And I know there is video
that has come out
to show how serious
the altercation did become,
but you got into a fight
that on Friday with an activist.
If this was anyone else,
would you say that
the person I just described
is serving their community well?
No.
Let me say this, Kate,
is that's not the person who I a
Let me underscore that
I have a body
and a history of progressive pol
that have improved the human con
for all individuals.
Regardless of who you are
and regardless
of where you come from,
regardless of color,
your skin or your legal status
or who you love or which God you
That's why I am.
I've made California
a 100% clean energy state.
I was sued by the Department of
under Donald Trump
when they made California
a sanctuary state.
I negotiated a deal to provide d
license for undocumented immigra
That's who I am.
And those are my values
and those are my principles.
That's not
the person who
folks have been describing.
And it's unfortunate
that, you know, then Councilmemb
Mike Bynum continues,
you know, his campaign against m
but I will continue to serve my
They will make the ultimate deci
and they will
it will be some time before vote
get to get a say once again on t
Thank you very much
for your time, Councilman. I ver
Good morning. Thank you.